hi guys dr. Berg here in this video we're going
to talk about restless legs syndrome I had this
condition in my 20s it drove me crazy I would get
up in the middle of night and pound my legs to go
run around the block to try to get this energy
out little did I know it's actually very easy to
fix there's two prime primary causes to this
number one there's a condition called lactic
acidosis that you may have and that is just a
buildup of lactic acid that deprives the muscle
of oxygen and there's a lot of restless quivering
and shaking and a feeling of electricity in your
legs and other muscles as well so if this is the
case you just simply need vitamin b1 but I like to
get it from nutritional use because most to be one
that you buy is synthetic the synthetic will still
work but you don't want to take it short long term
just may be short term but this is a b1 deficiency
and it works like within a day okay so this is
the more likely cause and this is an electrolyte
imbalance with a potassium deficiency okay now
you need a lot of potassium every day you need
like 4700 milligrams one banana is 300 milligrams
you need 4700 now how many times is 300 go into
4700 a lot was it 14 to 15 times so bananas aren't
going to cut it so the reason why you're deficient
in potassium there's three reasons one is you're
not consuming enough vegetable okay if you did you
get 2 potassium number 2 maybe your stomach is
not strong enough as far as the acid if you're
in the anti acid medication well then you don't
have the correct pH to pull them that potassium
because what causes acid reflux is a lack of acid
so you want to take apple cider vinegar or an acid
or betaine hydrochloride to be able to absorb
and get rid of the acid reflux so you can absorb
minerals in general so that's just a side note of
a lot of people that have this problem don't even
know it's connected to lack of absorption okay
so we have lack of dietary potassium number two
we have the stomach's not absorbing because
it's not acid enough number three you have a
blood sugar issue could be hypoglycemia could be
insulin resistance it could be diabetes all three
conditions you have a state where the insulin
is not working and it's not insulin controls
potassium absorption so if you don't have the
facility to even absorb potassium itself you
can get restless leg syndrome so I put a link down
below just to if you have blood sugar issues you
crave sweets or you're tired after you eat or
you could load it after you eat or you're not
fast enough to you eat or you crave whatever carbs
then you need to watch that video okay so you can
fix that but taking potassium will correct this
so you want to increase the vegetable but as an
immediate thing you can do is go to the health
food store go to Amazon and order some potassium
now the problem most people do is when they order
this they don't realize that you can really only
order this in 99 milligrams so you need
4700 milligrams so you don't have like 100 like
a lot of pills every single day right that's not
going to be workable so get the powder and get
potassium citrate okay and then what you can do
is dissolve it and do like maybe 700 milligrams
in some solution that's I mean and then do
another 700 like maybe a couple hours later
another 700 look so spread it out slowly through
the day do this for two days watch your legs it'll
just like feel so much better okay and then post
your comments below so I hope that helped but it's
totally an unnecessary condition you don't have to
take drugs and thank you for so much for watching